I dug through a graveyard of empty
bottles and missing pieces searching for
Redemption and turning debr to find the
reason everything is awful but it's only
in my brain the Vodka must be broken cuz
I don't feel
anything My Mind is Playing Tricks again
and only you can fix this you don't
answer when a call at night forgot how
much I miss this I've been H been crying
crying wol so long it's hard to believe
me anymore I've been I've been dying
dying for you but you will never mind so
good night and never
mind you were never mind so good night
and never
mind
you were never mind so good night and
never mind flipping through all pages of
lyrics I wrote to find the answers Lo
Myself Away in hotel rooms while I'm on
tour in Paris you're stuck in the moment
while I'm stuck on yesterday I give you
forever but you give it all away My Mind
is Playing Tricks again and only you can
fix is you don't answer when I call at
night forgot how much I missed this I've
been I've been crying crying WF so long
it's hard to believe me anymore I've
been I've been dying dying for you but
you were never mind so good night and
never
mind you would never mind so good night
and never
[Music]
mind you were never mind so good night
and never mind I came home to a dit on
not saying you lost hope and I'm never
going to get you back you said goodbye
in the Nick up time so don't ask why you
never going to get me
[Laughter]
back been H been crying crying wol so
long it's hard to believe me anymore
I've been I've been dying dying for you
but you will never mind so good night
and never
mind you never mind so good night and
never
[Music]
mind you were never mind so a never mind
I came home to a ditch on not saying you
lost hope and I'm never going to get you
back you said goodbye and the ni time so
me don't ask right but you never going
to got me
[Music]
back
hey friends so that's it my final flow
video of the year I figured go to one of
my favorite spots down in the National
Mall uh right outside of my favorite
museum and uh dance out to a song that
I've really been digging so I hope you
enjoyed it as much as I enjoyed making
it uh real quick I just want to put a
huge thank you out there to to ultra poy
for sponsoring this video and giving me
a reason to go out and play in DC uh
every month if you dug those or poy Pro
LED contact poy that I was using in this
video uh you can go pick up a set for
yourself and get a discount on them by
heading on over to ultra.com and using
the promo code Drex factor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout that'll get
you 5% off any prop in their online
store and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins thank you once again to
ultra poy for supporting my work and
this channel Channel and speaking of
thank yous uh got thanks to go out there
to the Friends of the channel uh big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and thank you
to the non- business friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission also this video would not
be possible without my awesome
supporters on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen now if
you would like to sign up to support
this work that I'm doing creating these
videos for people all over the world you
can do so by heading on over to
patreon.com factor poy and signing up
check that out please and thank
you um in the meantime thank you so much
for watching this video if you'd like to
see some more videos of me flowing out I
will include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description for
right now I hope your holidays have been
quite Merry and that you're getting out
and flowing regularly and I'll see you
in the new year with a brand new series
of videos thanks so much peace